[MUSIC]
History is the foundation
of a people's identity.
And when that foundation is lost,
it is catastrophic.
This is ever true when it
comes to African history.
This continent that made me,
the one that I love so
much, has been scarred
by modern day labels.
We all know instability,
poverty, corruption.
But this is not who we are.
Three years ago, I was sitting in
my CEO's office in East Africa,
when those words flashed across my mind,
I was working for
a multinational company and
was being heavily encouraged to sign
off on financial statements
that were a complete fiction.
I wanted this company to survive.
So I spent months meticulously
combing through these financials,
to make sure that the numbers were
accurate and actually useful.
Then one day,
my CEO calls me into a meeting.
She wasted no time.
She looked me right in the eyes and
she said, you are not doing
what I've asked you to do.
If you do not sign off,
I will destroy your reputation in Africa.
I could not breathe.
It felt like my body stopped working.
My mouth was so dry,
I was wondering if there was sand in it.
In this moment, I was about to
lose my job and my reputation and
all I could think was,
this is not who we are.
Here I was about to be another
casualty of the modern day narrative.
This cannot be who we are.
And it's not because our history
cries out a different reality.
In one illustration, we have the Edo
people from 14th century West Africa,
a people of which I am a descendant.
This city operated with
such a well-organized and
sophisticated communication channel
that if the city was under threat,
20,000 warriors can be notified and
ready for battle in one day.
Innovation was everywhere,
their whole city was fortified with
the largest earthwork in the world.
They trusted their King
to protect his people.
Yet no decision was made without
the approval of the Queen Mother.
And women weren't only sought out for
their wisdom.
They also protected their city by forming
their own armies and engaging in battle.
The natural resources of brass, copper and
ivory were used to create economic
stability through trade, and
also create beautiful striking artwork.
These people were not perfect, but
they were dedicated to their values.
In the 15th century, this vibrant
kingdom would be changed forever.
They would experience colonizers,
competence in conquering without
contemplating consequence.
After years of fighting for
survival, first with diplomacy and
then on the battlefield,
their city was burned to the ground.
Beyond the lives that were lost,
beyond the arts that was stolen,
these people were forced to
exist in a different way.
New culture, new religion,
new principles, carelessly scrambled
into a complex system that had been
carefully sculpted over hundreds of years.
It worked like a cancer.
Defined plans for
succession were uprooted and distrust was
planted among leaders leading to
political instability, medicinal and
scientific innovation was discouraged and
devolved into daily hacks for survival.
Generosity and
giving based on the seasons and
the times turned into transactional
exchanges motivated by self-interest.
This sad part of this story is
that eerily similar versions of
that story can be told about
dynasties across Africa.
Be at the kingdom of
Mutapa in Southern Africa,
the Swahili to the East,
the Kingdom of Ghana in West Africa and so
many other dynasties that would take
me the rest of this talk to list.
The African identity today has been
melted into one messy narrative struggle.
And we hear about it all the time.
Inflation in Zimbabwe, which is 175%.
30,000 people in Nigeria
have been displaced
due to the activity of Boko Haram.
Armed militants killed over
40,000 civilians in Mali, and
that was just in 2019.
Now let's be clear, we should not forget
the beauty, the cultural phenomena,
and the packets of progress that
exist on the continent today.
Powerful and passionate people,
African and not have put their money,
their research, their technology, and even
their lives to improve that continent.
But if we continue to ignore our past,
we will perpetually
misunderstand our presence and
create well meaning but
an adequate solutions for our future.
Now, I believe in the power of knowing and
internalizing history, because I have
witnessed it transform democracies and
the evidence is in this country,
even right here in this room.
And that's black America.
Now what he gave black America
remember its Holidays or
space in American history books for
the heroes of the past?
Black America history matters today
because people fought for it to matter.
Left it to some state governments, slavery
would be called the Atlantic triangular
trade, and abolitionists would be written
in as radicals or dangerous or not at all.
So when systems ignore the past by
slapping new names on old tricks, and
like things about mass incarceration and
what police brutality are today, voices
rise up armed themselves with the truths
of history and fight to course correct.
We, too,
in Africa can command the truths of our
history on our path towards progress.
So with that, I have one ask
of everybody in this room and
anybody watching this video.
I asked that you study one
story from African history.
There's so many good ones,
like the story of Lukeni Lua Nimi,
it's okay if you didn't catch that.
Just Google the first king of the Congo.
>> [LAUGH]
>> He was so thoughtful in his territorial
expansion, that he gave all of his new
districts the rights to protest and
reform his decisions.
That led to peace throughout his reign,
and for many years after.
Or what about the story of
King Caleb of the Kingdom of Aksum,
which is modern day Eritrea?
He would send his armies across the ocean
to protect people who are going
through religious persecution.
For those of you in this room who are not
from Africa, familiarizing yourself
with these stories, brings insights,
builds empathy and creates kinship.
Like my bro Anna talked about over here,
it's like learning a new language.
At first, you have little understanding.
Not because the language
is lacking in any way, but
because of your lack of knowledge of it.
As you continue to learn more,
you open up yourself to a whole new world.
Abstract, transcendence, and meaning and
you build a genuine
connection to my Africans.
It is time that we use our history as
a guiding light for the way forward,
there is an uncompromising power in
reclaiming back those identities.
It transforms the way that we see
ourselves and the way we see each other.
And it informs the decisions we
make no matter how tough they are.
Decisions like the one I had to
make in that office in East Africa.
That day, I chose to stand my ground.
Even though I was visibly shaken,
my foundation was not because
that label is not who I am.
I am the descendent of intentional
leaders who value justice.
I am the daughter of great women
who fought mighty your battles.
That is the Africa that
I choose to believe in.
That is the Africa that I carry with me.
That is who we are.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]